Speaker 1: Well, fox news host Steve Doocy
is off script again. I have to tell you,
i really do enjoy these clips. These are
clips were on the fox news morning show
fox and friends steve Doocy not because he's a
hero, not because he's now the arbiter of truth,
not because he's anything other than a Fox News
propagandist who sometimes just interjects a
little reality into the brains of his co-host for
whatever reason. Steve Doocy is making some what
in most of the real world are uncontroversial
admissions, but he's making them on Fox News,
and it's fascinating to watch. The latest one
here is steve Doocy saying, hey, you know,
the Biden economy actually is good. I mean, okay,
the white House maybe is having a messaging issue,
but the Biden economy really seems to actually
be functioning quite well. Take a listen to this.
And again, he's touting the numbers that we all
see. This is not extraordinarily obscure stuff.
Speaker 2: And that you have just touched on
the problem for the White House, and that is
they've got some pretty good numbers going on
right now. The jobs number is expected to come
out a little later on today. It's expected
to be about 252 and 25,000. Unemployment is
expected to drop down to 3.6%. Yesterday,
there was a blowout number. ADP said that
about a half a million jobs were added in June.
The construction sector itself added 97,000 jobs.
Speaker 1: This is this is not steve
Doocy making stuff up. It's just not
the place you would normally hear it in june.
Speaker 2: That's the biggest increase month
over month in a decade. So they've got these
pretty good numbers. But the White House is
stuck with a couple of people who are having
a problem selling it because people don't
feel like things are very good now.
Speaker 1: And the clip, of course,
from our friend Decoding Fox News, who does great
work typically on Twitter. Now, also on Threads,
you can find her decoding Fox News on on threads
as well. Steve Doocy is doing this a lot and I
don't want to attribute agency to what might be
randomness. This is, you know, forget about right
wing media, but there is so much scholarship and
I've read so much books that there's Nassim Taleb
fooled by randomness and done it. Daniel Kahneman
has written about this. In general, as humans,
we like to find patterns and and attribute agency
to phenomena in the world a really long time ago.
But when when pre-modern humans started to see
things move around in the sky and the sun come
up and go down or whatever. It would sometimes be
attributed to a man in the sky or some particular
force with agency, rather than sort of the
way that the laws of physics are impacting
celestial bodies. So we like as humans to put
agency and meaning and whatever. I can't do
that with Steve Doocy. I don't know that what's
happening here is that Steve Doocy has said,
you know, my network is spreading a lot of
disinformation. I'm going to go out there and
be the voice that tells a little bit of the
truth or something like, I have no reason to
think that that is what is going on. But Steve
Doocy has this habit of saying things that go
against the talking points of Fox News. Here's
one other really good example. This one's from
about a week and a half ago. This was related
to the supposed there was like a 72 hour period,
you might remember, where the Republicans became
obsessed with supposed evidence of Biden bribery.
It turned out that it's based on tapes they
don't have from a whistleblower who might not
be a whistleblower who they hadn't spoken to in
three years, who more recently we've uncovered has
never actually spoken to Joe Biden. So this one
evaporated quickly. But here was Steve Doocy sort
of saying, yeah, there really isn't evidence here.
Speaker 2: It is unclear what the joint venture is
or was. And if it was just for Biden corruption,
then why did they have other entities like they
had They mentioned Hudson and some other partners
as well. If it was just to influence a former vice
president, which I don't know if that's illegal,
why exactly were there so many other moving parts?
And what the Republicans don't do here yet is they
don't say if any laws were broken and if anything
was illegal. What they are.
Speaker 3: Saying.
Speaker 1: Right, it's quite simple. They've
not actually said what are the laws that were
broken and what is it that Joe Biden did
that is illegal? Make of it what you will
let me know in the comments. What you do
think what is going on with steve doocy.